[Music]
you do you i'ma do me well its attitude
like that it has bad girlfriend driving
everybody crazy on The Bachelor but
Monday night's episode of sure to drive
Corinne crazy because Nick is taking
Rachel on a date in New Orleans and only
easy aligns lauren zima was there to
witness their steamy chemistry
dancing caressing and making out in the
middle of the street things are starting
to heat up a little bit every moment
just keeps getting better it's the first
time the Dallas lawyer is getting a solo
date with Nick and he didn't disappoint
by throwing her parade and the Big Easy
I saw you guys kiss how do you feel like
it went I feel like I had this is the
best date I've ever known ever you know
and I'm 31 so I've been on a number of
dates before but this was fantastic I'm
like lost in the moment
clearly these two only had eyes for each
other despite being surrounded by at
least four cameras a dozen producers and
hundreds of fans eager to snap a photo
she's probably of all the women for me
from the very beginning one of the
easiest ones just kind of talked to jive
with she's just she's so kind of in her
element in any situation it gave me the
first impression rose and that's been
really nice but today me added the
romantic aspect to it like I can totally
see myself falling in love but sorry
Rachel it doesn't look as if Nick who is
on his fourth quest for love with the
bachelor franchise will be dropping an
album anytime soon
are you going in love I only want to say
I love you to one more person how would
you describe the whole process so far in
one word oh my gosh frustrating
[Music]